[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote webinar titled improving
research translation in dementia
humanized Mouse models cognition and
imaging this webinar is part of the 11th
annual event in the Neuroscience virtual
event series and I'm Susie Valdez of
labroots and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroots so
let's get started before we begin I want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our live chat
feature during this presentation you can
find that live chat located on the left
of of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of this
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
simply click on the help desk button
located at the top of your screen within
the navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
that continuing education credits link
located in the abstract tab from the
menu at the left of the screen and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
Marco pra a Canada Research chair in
neurochemistry of dementia and a
scientist at robarts Research Institute
and professor at the University of
Western Ontario for a complete biography
of our speakers please visit the
presenter tab from the menu at the left
of your screen Dr PR welcome you may now
begin your presentation
sir thank thanks Su so it's my pleasure
to be here and um I want to First just
thank La rots and for for this
invitation and also congratulate all the
women that are U participating for the
International Day of women um um and uh
you know my lab is run by uh the women
and and I have great women collaborators
and I'll try to highlight their work
today um I'm interested translational
research and particular in how we can
improve uh basic research to facilitate
translation uh CL trials and this is
just sort of a summary that U
uhal manufacturers America report that a
little bit of an idea of of the
magnitude of the problem in terms of uh
discovering new drugs and this is
particular problematic of brain and even
worse for dementia and and
neurodegenerative diseases um and you
can see that you know there there's OB
tag on on most of this what you can see
here is that um there's a lot of
compounds that need to be screened and
then you know there of preclinical
testing that has to happen before used
to clinical trials and the problem is
really that some of that
preal does not easily translate to
clinical trials and obviously clinical
trials are much much more expensive than
preclinical testing there is that we
could better predict which compounds or
which drugs that are effective in for
example animal models will successful in
clinical trials that would be uh a
really an amazing way to um you know
know perhaps uh um fail those drugs
really before you move to clinical
trials and save quite a bit on on on the
expenses of those clinical trials and
obviously there is a whole of reviews
that come up so so drug get the market
so where the arrow is is where I'm
interested is in improving that system
and a couple of examples of what we've
been doing to to do this and just a
reminder that for example for
Alzheimer's disease there is really no
drug recently that has been approved and
there's quite a bit of controversy on
the approval for example ad map and now
the which is a bit more
promising in terms of um uh um treatment
but still not U to the they actually do
what they supposed to do they um clear
the brain of of Alzheimer's pathology
but the Improvement in cognition is
somewhat um underwhelming
and that obviously is What patients
complain right if you have Alzheimer's
disease you're complaining of issues of
cognation of memory and that that's the
problem so how we do that sort of
preclinical research in the dementia
field or
neur most of what we do uses mice and
and this a lot from from um um
Foundation that uh uh highlights how
important the laboratory Mouse is for
research in life sciences and it just
gives an idea how
many um we can manipulate the most
genome uh in in a quite a remarkable way
and generate different mouth models for
diseases uh for Alzheimer's for Parkson
disease obviously you know this is a
work in progress uh what iation of m
models were trenic Mouse models uh and
we'll see now that we're evolving to
Mouse models where we have
knocking the um human genes sometimes in
the mouse genome and and try to improve
those Mouse models so so the first thing
that think is is the sort of model and
you know as George B stated um um no
model is useful no model all models are
wrong and my are obviously not human but
we can learn quite a bit of uh disease
process and pathology in mice and we
hope that we can also learn about how
pathology affects for example cognition
and uh
structure so what are the issues so I I
just raised one issue is you know we we
do need m models we need Mouse models
that better reflect the disease and I'm
going to give you a few examples how
we're doing this and part of a a large
consort M trap and a partnership between
my university University of Western
Ontario and MC University to do that
sort of improvement and how we evaluate
uh drugs and and develop met dollars for
this so um in terms of measurements that
you can do in in for models of
Alzheimer's disease other dimensia you
know the Cent approach is really to use
Behavior tests that might be IR relevant
for because they have to escape
something or they get some sort of uh
you know they're afraid of something and
you measure that that sort of fear
but they're not translatable for humans
so so for example the most common sort
of test for memory mice in in Mouse
models of Al is either fear condition
you know sort of fear based memory or uh
something called the mors water maze
which mice are put in the PO and they
have to escape and obviously you don't
do that in Alzheimer's disease right you
don't throw Alzheimer's patients in and
ask to figure out how they get out
there's a huge component of stress
there moreover uh and and pre you know
one of the things that we don't do is is
the sort of Imaging that you can do and
um uh in humans for example using
sophisticated MRI technology I mean we
do it but it's not a common thing to do
mostly we rely on biochemical markers
and sort of we doubt for this
neurodegenerative disease in Mouse
models and we think we can do better
than that you know we if you think about
models of dementia is really in in
cognitive dysfunction you want to test
something that can reflect what you see
in humans which is the cogni function
that affects their living but how how do
you do that in a mouse obviously you
can't ask the mouse about this so you
also want to do something
that's that it's relevant and may be
relevant for The Human Condition as well
uh you want you want a test that is
reproducible and can be easily
reproduced between labs and and and it
provides enough power to understand the
cognitive functions that you're
interested in you want Automation and
potentially you want some sort of
standardization as well so different
Laboratories can do this and can use
it over you'd like some sort of medium
to high throughput so you can multiple
Mouse models multiple drugs you want to
do some sort of
Imaging to use humans and may serve as
translatable biomarkers and same thing
for the cognition right so so in terms
of uh translational measurements what we
use in our um approach here is a set of
touchscreen tasks so the this basically
iPads for mice um so the mice have to
touch the screen and there is over 30
validated task that have my colleagues
team busy and Lisa saeda my colleagues
from the University of
West and so
there completely automated the computer
takes over and test mice um the standard
results can be provided by the computer
but most
important U tests are identical to human
tests that we can test humans and mice
with absolutely the same task the sort
of image we do for example it's high
field MRI we can do uh a number of
bra
analysis experts in
um magnetic resonance imaging so just to
to you a quick example this touch screen
task that is developed for mice and used
in mice and those are based in in in the
C sort of
um of test and and that's the advantage
of those touch screens because you
battery tests similar to human don't you
don't need to do just that of them and
this particular one my colleagues tested
mice uh in this the mice that have
mutation that
cause fail this task and then the test
humans in the same sort of test that's
on on on on the left and um you can see
that the humans that had the same that
were produced in mice also failed in the
same so they're translatable and they
some of the uh uh changes in cognition
so I'm going to focus in two examples
I'm going to focus on um
sinuc such as parkson's disease diens
with Louis body that's going to be my my
main example on how we're developing
this sort of translational approach I'll
give you a little bit of an Alzheimer's
at the end of it as well and copath are
really dises where a protein called aluc
Mis so Alpha sycle normally is involved
with synaptic vles and synaptic
transmission we know it does but in
parkson's disease demential with Lou
body uh multiple system atrophy and a
number of other diseases that protein me
changes confirmation it starts to make
inclusions eventually forms oligomers
and and and Aggregates and they're so
called those and Lou neurites are formed
by this Meed and aggregated um sinuc and
that obviously so that's one of the main
features of a number of patients with
parkson's disease the with Lou as well
so we think
sin are an important component there is
quite a bit of uh human and and and
preclinical research evidence so this is
um a paper from from a few years ago and
and actually shows something that is now
quite common for this
neur is that this pathology uh can
transfer from cell to cell in what we
call a pron like
Behavior are the proteins that LE fold
and cause preum disease like cross
disease so parel disease is not a preum
disease but
it preum as the pathology progresses
through the brain and this is an example
of this sort of experiments where uh
actually uh what people did here what
researchers did here uh led by uh
Patrick Ry was to uh grab tissue from
from U you know f f tissue to replace
the Pinar neurons that are lost in Lost
in Parx disease so this is one of par
disease dopamine neurons die and affects
movement affects cognition affects
number so they
gra F that would po secrete parks of
disease but what they found is that you
know the pathy from the host actually is
present also in in the graph tissue well
and um if you look at uh sinuc is small
protein but that you can of that
misfolding for example sinuc may be
related uh in one specific res uh
um and that is marker of sort misfolded
and aggregated sin we don't know if
that's is toxic or not we know that you
know most of us use so if you look at
the brain here and that scheme of the
brain and there you know this whole U
pathology U stage at bra and bra
described uh where the pathology is
moving on the brain stem and it's moving
towards the and you know affecting The
Quon obviously when it gets to uh uh
some of the major centers that's when
symptoms start to appear uh and this
case of of copes such as Sparks disease
but it's similar for Alzheimer's disease
and other diseases as well there's the
big problem here so somehow the proteins
that normally work to facilitate how our
brain cells communicate they
change they they are normally folded
they misfold and somehow they form the
inclusions start to aggregate they can
transfer from neuron to neuron can
spread to Connected Pathways in the
brain so how does that uh happen um you
know one possibility is that proteins
named molecular shaper participate in
this process molecular chaperons are a
set of proteins that um are involved in
and U organization of large proteins
complex so one of the best examples is
the heat shock and heat shock protein 90
chaon Pathways where you have a number
of other proteins Cal chapons that
participate in
this and those molecular chapons help to
maintain proteins folded but they can
also to uh uh uh support them to be
either degraded or or destroyed and and
it's important that the
sh really really well and and and I
mentioned last example is the shock
protein 90 which is a dimer and
interacts with what we call client
proteins such as you know
sinuc and there is evidence that the shs
are important for nucle there is a paper
that uh was published a few years ago uh
by
Sebastian and in this paper they show
that cukan is either located at the
membran of vasul or other types of
membrane but if it's in the cytoplasm
cell is is probably complex with with
with shars so it complex with uh H shock
protein that led us to ask the question
whether the shapos might be affected in
parts of disease and this is a
collaboration with we did with the Monas
at the
Hebrew and and she looked at a number of
those chapons and Kos chapons on top and
in the left are the chapons and po
chapons
that um differental expression they
increased in people died of disease and
in have that don't don't change that
much we also look at the base and look
at how chapons correlate with sinuc and
kons on the left on the L call they they
they do show some correlation with with
sinuc but because they
change expression that correlation is
not as strong as the chapons that don't
change expression in the in in parks and
seeds and we're particularly interested
one of those po chapons called inducible
phosphor protein
one1 or sti1 one there different names
for this protein and it's a CR protein
that actually uh
regulates transfer of proteins between
uh H shock protein 7 and H protein 19
it's important for the function of this
molecular so we're interested to see
whether this protein would would be
participa somehow with sinine and would
be regulating chapons and did was to ask
the question whether there's some sort
of interaction between one and an alpha
sycle because you know there was this sh
intercine and we did find that um witho
precipitate ST1 which is shown here uh
in this Western plots we alsate mouse
mouse slean and we also coate heat shock
protein 90 as a complex obviously this
just says the ST1 is in a complex with
with Alpha it doesn't tell us that
reacts directly but that we did um PR a
colleague named James Troy a biochemist
and he used nuclear magnetic
resonance uh to look at chip and
proteins so we label proteins I'm not
going to go in detail how this is done
but we basically label proteins and put
those proteins together and um see
changes chemical shift changes in one
protein in this case in nucle when we
trate and we see that is happening
basically what this
uh is showing is that the C terminals of
of interacts with one of the domains of
ST1 called the tpr2a domains uh a lot of
other exper no other domain interacts
with with uh s nucle and if we do the
reverse experiment we see that is the
tpr2a domain that it changes also on
stf1 one interact s so there is direct
interaction so we interested in looking
at this invivo because remember we want
to see whether we can do better
cognition and better Imaging and and and
may be able to better project how this
uh Pathways work for a clinical Tri um
we use a model of alpha signle called
the um uh
a53t M83 mice which is best Alpha sinle
uh that is a human Alpha sinine is a
trenic mouse uh if you have two copies
of that that trans
Gene develops spontaneous disease and in
the western plot you can see so when I
uh I have this M3 homoy mice I'll
have and I'll have a mouse without any
of marker there um and you can see that
for example if you look at um solation
of sinuc in 129 which is the middle of
this Western block you see that M3 must
have way more fation of this marker and
they have ST1 obviously we we labeled
for everything else we use the same of
mouse model with one copy of of Alpha so
we can two copies or one copy of the T
and this Cas copy what we do is we can
inject and you can see here in this
cartoon we inject what we call preformed
fibers of human sinle that basically
serves as a seed and template to change
the confirmation of sinuc and you can
have and this sort of to mimic this PR
like Behavior where you have different
strains of sinuc that can be injected in
the brain so IM
Tre so that has one copy it doesn't have
any abnormalities until they really
really old but we can see this pathology
and you can see here what you can see is
in the top uh blue uh um micrography is
mice that work with PBS you see nothing
nothing there and with this preform
fibos we can detect the phosphated
cleine and that You' seen red here and
you can see that spread so injecting one
of the and it it basically from where
that se is injected this Tri in the stum
it uh go through connected Pathways to
different brain areas so go to Connected
Pathways to different PR areas and we
can detect the misfolded alpha with
fated alph thing that is fent in red
here and you can look at this in more
details and you can see that the here
and red um uh in neurons and different
brain regions uh it colocalizes with
inclusions
of with h shock protein 90 and ST1 so
when have the mouth model that we
injected or preformed
FiOS the cartoon mes with a little
injection on top so so you know which
one I'm talking about so um the first we
you know obviously we saw in patients
that this uh uh shars are somehow
increased you know what's happening in
the mice and what found to make a really
long story short is that um Shar seem to
be abnormal in this mouse models of copy
and you can IGN the blots and just go to
the graphs and in this graphs you can
see that in all the moue models this uh
uh shap such as heat protein 90 and stl1
are increased levels but this is
aggregated chaon so this a of aggregated
protein so these chaun are now
aggregating so they they seem to be
abnormal this is in the homozygous mice
BFF mice we also see that sort of same
sort of thing where where in the
aggregated form this sh GRE which would
should not be
increased um so the question we ask them
is uh uh really you know if we have uh
this normal she so maybe we need to
replace them they're not working really
well you know what happens if we
increase the levels of this protein
called S1 and we did this in different
ways but you know basically what happens
is that theology actually got worse if
we had more S1 in this case we also had
more heat shock protein 90 it is a enic
Mouse model we made few years ago and we
crossed them with the
imary them with with the with the pffs
and we saw you can compare the left and
right and in the right you can see way
more red because there is more pathology
we can see that individual neurons as
well there is more pathology and we can
quantify this and you know the
quantification shows the same thing wey
it by Western plots and you can see here
Western plots that if you look at this
129 this sinclear 129 is if have more
mice that have more ST1 and more hp90
VAR more of this um uh C labels this
agre inclusion misfolded same um we see
this both in the Sol fractions but also
fractions as well really suggesting that
that there is um you know some sort of
abnormality going on uh we can um do
uh uh the sort of experiment now in to
try to understand how this is happening
and in this particular one it what we
did here is that we phosphorated Alpha
this region 129 so what you see in this
Square in the Middle where 129 residue
should be reflected in the plot but you
can see that is right in the left
because it's fully phosphorated the
phosphorated protein can still interact
and even interact a bit better with ST1
and what we did one initro experiment
that turned out to be quite where we put
uh this domain of ST1 that interacts
with cleine and we fated clean in vitro
and what we and you can look at the
graph here to to see this is that when
we put the right domain that interacts
with sinuc which is this
tpr we increase the levels of fation of
sinoc vitro so J in that some uh St one
can
hold in confirmation that favors that
that pathological or or abnormal fation
that that increasing
that so we um uh obviously ask the
question that if increased levels of
stm1 are fac increasing sorty is
decreased levels doing the inverse and
obviously the answer it is uh this is
the question ification if you look at
the red you can see the normal sort of
uh preformed fiber injected mice um have
whereas the mice that have in this case
is a mice that have about 80% decrease
levels of a mutated ST1
so one you can see that in the right
that there is way less of the red marker
of
pathology so that to obviously we got to
quantify this we we do the W BLS again
and and you don't have again to worry
about the Western blots just to show you
you know the quantification of the
western blots shows that you know you
can decrease quite a bit of theology um
if you have one or two copies of the
mutated
EST basically what I'm telling you that
if you increase levels St one you're
increase increasing pathology if you're
decreasing the levels of one you are
decreasing pathology okay so so what I
told you so far and and it's just sort
of a prep to tell you how we now hope to
look at this in in ways that will
facilitate uh uh translation measures uh
between the m models and people with
thetion so just as a reminder then um so
we have this uhle uh we have Mouse model
ofan that over Express human sinine
depending if it over Express a lot it
develops spontaneous disease if it a lot
we can uh trigger Disease by injecting
this formed fibbr or PFF human
SLE like a seed changes information and
we think that hp90 and
ST1 they
act um uh um to basically regulate this
process and facilitate foration by this
kind of of this this abnormal formation
the same time the the shs are abnormally
in in this disease and they together
with Alpha sinle and this uh sort of
inclusions that we're detecting mice so
how do we detect this and how we move
with this so so we want to at early
biomarkers and I mentioned this about
the touch screens we I mentioned this
about sort of Imaging I'm not talk about
this in know in a way we want to also um
maximize chances by using different
models not just in the case of of the
group that I'm working and the consorti
that we work we use the common marmoset
as a model as well and I'm going to show
you developing the marmoset models of
sinuc opathy right now so uh just to
give an idea uh this is a paper that
submitted and and uh inject the pffs
like we did the preform fiber
we brain uh matter after the brain after
about three months in a mice and we can
actually do this longitudinally with the
live mice as well this is a
collaboration with my colleague malara
but is really D Stephanie Tulu one of
his grad students and we also in my lab
detected um uh using the screen tasks
detected uh dysfunction and that would
be the lower back of this graph
cognitive dysfunction that is very early
about 30 uh days of PF so when
progression of the pathology is
happening so top of on the top here is
different motor test that did and we the
SM are absolutely normal by 30 days in
the motor tasks but we can already
detect um a cognitive death particular
task which is their wise visual
discrimination and reversal learning uh
weiz two different images and we reward
one of that so really nice um shot of
strawberry milkshake if they get it
right they don't get it right they don't
get it so they sort of get punished by
some tone and some noise um and you can
see that they they learn how to
discriminate those two images and the
first time they do you know uh both the
control and the PFF which is in pink
they are the same they do the same but
when we go and reverse the contingence
that is we change now reward
the let's say we're rewarding first uh
the left image and then uh we we start
rewarding the Right image this start
right and and when we do this you know
and we've seen the the the the graph
here uh is there is a difference and and
the we to differentiate those two images
and the um mice injector with PFF the
worse and and I'll show you this in in a
different way
in and point to you to the paper that we
just published with this data uh this is
a paper that was published recently in
ACTA neur uh has all this data that I
mentioned to you so so again this is the
sort of test that we do so we have this
what fan and and so doing acquisition
and here we have you know control mice
wild type mice M3 mice that have uh um
have two copies of of of of the trans
and M3 mice that have L ST1 in blue so
uh sorry so in blue is the M3 mice that
has two copies of the renic mice and in
um um in pink we have the M3 that one so
if we ask them to learn which of those
two images gives the reward they learn
in in few trials you know takes a few
days but they learn and they their
performance is the same but you can see
in the reversal learning when they are
you know on the top they in accuracy
about 80 means that they're getting
eight right and then we change the
contingence now we start rewarding the
other image and they have to learn that
the other image now is going to give
them strawberry obviously in the
beginning they fail completely and then
they get maybe one or right but they
started to relearn this and obviously
they they more do it they relearn oh no
that's now the other image that that
does so they have to inhibit their
behavior of touching the image they were
touching before and touch the new image
you can see that control M to this quite
well the the blue line where you have
the you can see they have a deficit
compared to control mice and you can see
that if the uh trenic mice have one last
copy of S1 so they have lower levels of
stl1 we can mitigate that cognitive
defis not only that if we look at the
Imaging MRI
imaging again we can see it and and and
we can just look at the graphs and what
we're showing is that in the blue is
that the trenic mes have certain brain
regions um that are similar to what you
expect to see in in in um people with
send an office and but if you have
reduced levels of ST1 you sort of
mitigate that atrophy and these are the
same mice that did the cognitive so
suggesting that now that um uh that by
decreasing the levels of stf1 we can
mitigate not just the but we can
mitigate cognitive deficits that are
very relevant for human sycle that sort
of executive dys learning is the sort of
thing that you expect to see in in in
patients with with the with Louis body
and and even some parks's
patient so what does that take us so one
of the uh uh things that is happening
and I mention is that this shap shap be
affected there is a a hypothesis that
was um raised by my collaborators
Gabriel koses that suggest that and
protein misfolding the whole chaon
system is affected and is behaving
abnormally and EP shapon so they're
highly connected and they seem to
somehow this abnormal chaperon seem to
hold Pro that instead of help helping
them to be destroyed so they don't work
as well as they should work and she
developed a number of approaches
including a drug that could be used to
disrupt this abnormal Epic
so so basically this shop that is highly
connected and you can see that the key
nodes that connects this whole thing
together so Gabriella showed that if you
knock down ST1 you can the and if you
use a drug that interacts with the hp90
that facilitates the hp90 that is in
this EP shop room uh you can block this
sh so there's a drug called puad that
does that is a drug that is actually on
clinical trials for uh Alzheimer's
disease and the first um
um phase of the clinical trials just
been reported a few months ago and
showing that this drug
is it you know has the right
pharmacokinetics um so it's this EP
shapon inhibitor and the drug is from
here so it's called and and the idea is
that they will interact with this EP
shapon with hsp90 and and disrupt this
eph so we asked the question why perhaps
or you know this drug since we' seen
that chaon are affected also in paron
disease and or or sopy M M would that
affect cogn and these are preliminary
results but you know using the same sort
of uh reversal learning testing that we
did and you here the reversal learning
top and this is done in male and female
mice and you can see that in is the mice
that have been injected with this
preform files and they have obviously
the death that we detected before we can
reproduce this but if they have treated
with this
drug that that that interferes withum
you can see that we can mitigate this
cognitive St so obviously this is just a
small step uh we you know our pipeline
would indicate that we have to look at
this more careful we're going to do a
number exping a number of other controls
uh we're passing different m models of s
opathy and if this drug really uh
improves cognition the second cognitive
task that we're doing that also um um
responds to this preformed fibers and by
the way I mean we've tested different
preform FIB we tested our preformed
fibers we test for a company called
stress marker and it works in the same
way as well uh so so seems quite a
robust finding that the comination goes
first and we can detect this cognitive
Defence um so once we we we fully
validate this m perhaps in organoids
then we may move to then to uh the
marmoset and that will be the ultimate
proof so marmosets obviously def close
closer to humans the immune system is
much much closer to humans and we can
now so we're already doing the sort of
same cognitive
test and um and mice and ween humans as
well so I just want to uh start start to
finish this about five minutes to give
you a take-home message
in a quick other example so so ST1 is is
Major play interacts with the protein um
but we we do think that is participating
in the misfolding of of of fosen and to
be EP shapon I think that is a shapon
may be a potential therapeutic and even
diagnostic for cop opathy so this is
just one example quickly going to move
to a second example um in Alzheimer's
disease and and just to I'm not going to
give you Anya for example in terms of
better mouth models we have generated
mouth models where we have umum M AP
which Theo precursive protein that
reproduce some of the familiar forms of
Alzheimer's disease we have mice that
have also human and this has not been
generated by us but by others and also
and one of the uh really important
resources is the mod we uh consortion in
the US and and and R as well and and A3
and A4 but what we did was we combined
all one Mouse model actually different
Mouse models so we have mice that have
mutated or not mutated AP they have to
it's important to have human towel
because you have different uh towel
forms and uh you have the biggest risk
for Alzheimer is A4 and and the normal
risk which is A3 and we you know one
thing that we're doing not just generate
this mice but then we go in the battery
of this cognitive T screen test we test
in a battery of Imaging modalities and
and and then we you know and this is
some mod that this consortial has tested
so
far and some of the cognitive platforms
that we've used um we do our open
science initiative and uh we have
different ways to foster open science we
have something called touchscreen
cognition. org that you know it's for
all the members of the community that
use this touchcreen there's about 400
Laboratories in the world including a
number of pharmaceutical and this is
really to share knowy and standard
operating procedures for touch screens
we also have a data sharing platform
called Mouse and I urge you to check it
out uh through www mousebot Mouse
b.ca and I mean we publ few years ago
and E life and this is part of what we
call a mouse trap platform so Mouse
transation research ofat platform that
provides uh support for researchers to
test their uh Mouse model test the drugs
so you can
see access free anybody can be uh can
download all the data sets there are
public uh
there's individual Minds questioned with
their cognitive data available in this
uh uh database and this is just example
of the users of people that use this
mouse by uh technology or or or platform
to um um download data set so uh the
advantage of those touch screens is that
you really can have um some sort of
standardization without needing to have
a cons together right so people all over
the world can use the same apparatus and
same sort of um
uh uh uh standard operating
procedure uh types of data sets and I
mean the stud screens are commercially
available but we also working on
potential uh open source touch screen
there others that have worked on on open
source touch screen this led to u a
recent initiative a partnership that we
have with so similar to what people do
clinical trials we wanted like it's gone
the days that one scientist is going to
do experiments in
so we have this as a m site sort of
facility so we have a partnership with M
University and we have testing drugs and
organoid so it's called the translation
initiative to do risk neurotherapeutics
and make it safer to move to clinical
trials not safer in terms of you know uh
potential harm but safer in terms of
better chance of of this drugs uh in
humans when we pass to this pipe line
which is uh uh patient Organo testing
mice and it's a pyramid obviously the
mar is what we think is really really
promising and we do this through Imaging
cognition and through open science as
well U just going to finish here so um
this obvious hopefully will lead you
know this is a test platform and
hopefully when we finish this project in
a few years we know better chance of
sucess for clinical tries so of success
so this is really are ongoing but you
know it's increased
reproducibility different and this
screen really as well have really high
rate of reproducibility we can you know
people can crowdsource data can reuse
the data so follow the fair principles
of of open science uh increase access to
open science we hope there going to be
better understand of the secrets and
patholog that involve the cognition um
they platforms for drug testing and and
synergize the efforts for for for better
understand how this drugs uh could
predict the success of drug for trial so
um that's pretty much it I want to just
thank the people that have involved with
this and because today is for women I I
want to really give a shout out to the
major people that were involved um
including my partner um in
life uh who who directs this program
with me uh Rachel ly who is a grad
student graduated last year she most of
what we've done with sing and L the
project alen Miranda is a professor in
Brazil but was a postdoc in the lab and
she did a lot of behavior Anan is a GRE
post do that is following up with this
project Lisa Saka is from the from the D
B is is another great collaboration Mona
another of the amazing women that I have
the privilege to collaborate my
collaborator poses in in New York that
has provided us with the drug and
insight on Happy shops and S M as well
who um uh develop this uh M bites uh
platform and um I just uh you know
obviously a number of other people have
been involved and you know shut out they
all there um they have different levels
involvement as well but I I thought I
just shout out for the women that have
the
particip some of the major initiatives
uh have been funded uh by a number of
organisms in Canada International uh
it's ouros and I'm be really happy to
answer any questions if there are any
thank you very much for your
attention and thank you Dr pra for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen so let's
get started it looks like we already
have some great questions coming in our
first question Dr Paro from our audience
he said uh I understand that this gas
has been personalized in case of AD but
is there an possibility a possibility
for the same therapeutic to be available
for other neurogen degenerative dis
orders like Ms or
ALS oh that's a really excellent
question thank you for that um so so the
concept of Epic shaums is also um is
also being studied in other neurod
degenerative disease not in in multiple
sclerosis but in in amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis yes um which is a also
misfolding um this in that case there's
other proteins that misfold such as fuzz
tdp43 is the major misfolded protein
chapons are important for tdp43 as well
and um it's it's not been tested yet
it's there is potential that this sort
of EP shapon could be uh used for other
neurod degenerative diseases as well uh
the platform and and and the sort
pipeline that that we um put towards
Alzheimer's or towards sinuc opathy just
U um parts of this for our disease as
well and and we do have different models
of ALS or from the temporal Dimension
which is sort of
ALS uh and it's evolved mutations of
tdp43 so we have and we have tested some
of these Mouse models this line as well
so you know obviously there is a
capacity issue but we uh you know having
the capacity we we nowadays I
test in the touch screens for example
about 5 to 800 mil every day right and
and this is involving different projects
new models and testing drugs like I I I
um pointed out so yeah so there is a lot
of potential for diseases as well not
just the Alzheimer's disease and parel's
disease thank you so much and how can
how can one act access the facilities
you mentioned in your
talk yeah so you know we really sort of
um still sort of starting this but um we
have a a website a
website um so if you Google mouse trap
uo for Western you find or or a website
uh that shows that you know of abilities
we have uh we will uh do uh
consultations to do a feif for service
type of thing but it has to be sort of
aign weed in uh but we do have the
possibility of doing sort of Fe for
service uh even though we like I said
you know we're well right now and and
sort of overwhelmed but you know if
there is something that is really sort
of um um Theory PR par disease F then we
have for example connections with major
cons like model ad and other consor so
if there is a really a pressing drug we
could divert efforts to test that in our
Pipeline and and move on to the PIP
of as well thank you so much and we have
a couple other questions coming in how
do you think other chaperon such as
hsp90 participate in the suo pathies
sorry about that yeah cathes yeah yeah
so it just P9 is the major Shar it
obviously from from more data it does
have an important effect we we think
that is sort of this Hub of the EP shaum
and in on this particular drug that we
are
testing drug that actually interacts
with the confirmation of heat shock
protein 90 that is involved and uh um in
this EPA room so so we do think that is
is a it's an interesting Target people
have been looking at this for quite a
while
not sh Fe regulated and targeting this
regulated shop might be a a sort of what
we think might be one of the viable
approach I mean there's certainly other
approach that people
using antibodies against misfolded
proteins and helping different companies
to test those as
well thank you very much and we have one
final question coming in how long does
it take train mice in touchscreen
cognitive
tests yeah so so obviously it takes a
while uh uh uh the mice need to be um uh
uh first you know they have to have the
touch screens they have to learn to you
know it's not like humans that you just
give you know when the human test to
give the touch screen and let them
figure out in a mouse test we do the we
coach the mouse to you know first they
have to learn they have to touch theen
and type of test that we're going to and
and there's like I said 30 test that
different cognitive M uh I showed
reversal learning but we can test
attention we can test a memory and
learning um it takes about really on the
task it takes about 15 days to train
them to use the touch screens and it may
take about 15 more days to to a month to
to do the cognitive
test so it takes about a month uh to to
get this going obviously but you know it
if you have the capacity and in our
capacity you can do multiple different
touch screen Chambers so like I said we
test about you know five up to 800 mil
every day and this is also a a
technology that allows us to do a lot of
neurot so can manipulate you know I know
you're part of the brain initiative uh
there is a lot of disc
so using
optogenetics
using genetics with the stch screens is
really easy because everything is time
and automated and on top of everything
we can use other n such as recording
with minis Scopes or or fetometry so
recording neurotransmitters recording uh
changes neur all that can be also
adapted with
this Dr PR I want to thank you for your
presentation and your time today would
you like to provide any closing remarks
for our audience before we
go no I just want to thank you for for
your uh PTI for your attention and and
and again I want to congratulate you Su
and all the women for for the day for
the for today and you know all the
amazing work amazing contributions that
women do for not just for science for
Humanity thank
you and thank you very much and thank
you again for your important research
before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during on demand period will
be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
March 8th 2025 labrats will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone
bye-bye
bye